well the nfl rarely is known for its
strict uniform rules closely
regulating teams uniforms even socks
gloves shoes but once a year there is an
exception to the
shoe stipulation and that's because of
my cause
my cleats kevin martin has more on how
some of the raiders are taking part in
this campaign
since 2016 nfl players have been raising
awareness for non-profit organizations
through the my cause
my cleats campaign and this year a
record-breaking number of players are
taking
part providing an unprecedented platform
to bring causes they are most passionate
about to the forefront
when they take the field in these
one-of-a-kind cleats on game day
of the more than one thousand players
participating several
are las vegas raiders who will be
supporting causes that include
topics such as tackling social injustice
supporting the american cancer society
and for fullback alec ingold a cause
that is particularly close to his heart
ingrold will take the field in these
cleats in support of teammate
darren waller and his foundation earlier
engel tweeted out this message in
support of his fellow raider
saying quote i don't have firsthand
experience with substance abuse but i
have seen how
darren can change and impact lives he
changed mine
these raiders will join other players
from around the league
over the next two weeks wearing these
custom cleats for the my cause
my cleats campaign covering the raiders
in las vegas i'm
kevin martin